when she had the accent a lot of
headlines wanted to find an association
between drugs or alcohol the coroner
found that had nothing to do with the
accident do you feel like Anne is
Vindicated yeah you know that's a tough
question I'm not gonna lie I feel angry
about it because I knew it was 10 30 in
the morning she was not under the
influence of alcohol and drugs played no
impact I don't know that we will ever
know uh what happened it was a tragic
accident she was misjudged not only in
this accident but you know back in the
90s like her whole existence she was
misjudged why do you feel like Anne was
so misunderstood because she stood up
for gender-free love in the 90s it
hadn't been done and took a big hit for
it she didn't do a studio picture for
for 10 years she was blacklisted she was
ridiculed and I always thought it was
very unfair that nobody ever circled
back to make it right
E.T was exclusively with Heather last
night as she was joined by Anne's 13
year old son Atlas and his father James
Tupper they sat front row at a book
reading for the late actresses candid
posthumous Memoir call me Anne this
would have meant the world to Anne and
was a devoted Mom how are the boys doing
now they're great Homer's 20 he's going
to be 21 soon he's more independent
Atlas he's an incredible kid they're
both incredible kids it's been really
hard for them but they're they're doing
okay Heather told us she's also working
on documentary to celebrate Anne's Life
and Legacy did you guys ever talk about
what she wanted her Legacy to be all the
time it's moving the needle for lgbtq
plus it's it's living a life of honesty
she was all about spreading love and
kindness and and truth and
it's a shame she's not here today but
her her message goes on
[Music]